salut ses lunettes 100 sur mon visage
vous ne savez donc pas quechua je vais
désormais la retirez vous découvrirez
qui se cache derrière brad pitt des
années je me suis souvenu d'un site qui
m'a rendu profondément je me suis retenu
l'utiliser mais ça m'a rendu une
nostalgie que j'ai de revoir le nom ceux
qui s'asseyent web archives web
archive.org si vous connaissez oui non
peut-être aux là je préfère les tutos
beauté tu te calmes en gros tu peut
sauvegarder une page par exemple
sauvegarde est actuellement bas le lien
de la chaîne youtube comme ceux-ci objet
la sauvegarde et dont cinq en six ans
quand je retournais son wave machines et
ben je pourrais voir à quoi ressemble et
ma chaîne youtube
au moment où j'ai fait cette archive en
2021 2022 si on est encore sur youtube
mais qu'on pourra regarder star chine
eh ben on va commencer par magie du
regarder la plus vieille archive et je
remercie la personne qui a acquis la
fête ce que c'est pas automatique choix
elle date 2 avril 2016 regarder ça vous
rappelle les souvenirs on était à cinq
millions huit cent cinquante six mille
abonnés et on a vu ce fonds là et je
venais de sortir le clavier challenge
tomassi a pas si longtemps ça 19 avril
2016 tient plus d'un an le ton post vite
ce qui nous arrive septembre 2011 nom
qui aurait sauvegarder un truc de
septembre 2011 mais ça va pas personne
fait ça
[Musique]
le 10 octobre 2011
voilà à quoi ça ressemblait alors les
plus jeunes d'entre vous seront
totalement choqués par la gueule calmes
et youtube mais savait vraiment ce de
galles ça c'était la photo de machette
mais que ça paraît tellement loin c'est
excellent j'avais 8857 abonnés oui c'est
comme ça que ça a fusé je me souviens
[ __ ] c'est un truc de revoir ça le
youtuber le plus déjanté de youtube vous
offre ces crises et comment tu as he is
bond j'aime aussi que l'on m'envoie des
idées des beaux qu'ils des feuilles
voire même des critiques négatives afin
de l'améliorer car je n'arrive pas à
faire des vidéos sans l'aide des gens
avril 2012 ça c'était là sa [ __ ] c'est
moi c'était un vrai à une révolution je
trouve de youtube vous avez donc là
j'avais changé mon fond et j'avais pu
mettre une petite bannière et tu peux
mettre des liens cliquables
et oui mon ami et j'avais 9 millions 500
mille vies au total et 85 mille abonnés
ça j'en garde un très bon souvenir cette
époque c'est vraiment ce époque j'ai
commencé à faire des jeux d'avoir je me
souviens scp 0,87 était déjà lorsque je
faisais elle est un peu de podcasts un
bref le viol youtube quoi en 2013 risque
avait d'accord ouais donc l'un des deux
jeunes et vieux hommes y avait un bug
avec mon image youtube c'est totalement
de hockey a ensuite en juin 2014
bastille le design qu'on a connue
pendant très très longtemps bref mais je
me demande à quoi puisque j'étais pas là
au tout début de twitter à quoi
ressemble et twitter mais qu en 2001
retiens de mes seins ce très bien ça ne
sais pas si ça va un peu vieillot mais
c'est pas si terrible je trouve ces
gentils aujourd'hui tu pourrais encore
de région décide comme ça et ça te fait
pas paniquer alors de messi loisirs va
peut-être pas remonter trop emballé en
2006 comment c'était en 2006 vc vide
mais non mais il manque un fonds spa
possible une communauté d'amis et
d'étrangers qui répondent à une seule et
simple question qui était en train de
faire à la base c'était juste ça c'est
juste un statut 10 ans ce qui est en
train de faire je savais pas moi j'ai
rejoint twitter traders en 2012-13 je
sais plus je rejoins super tard donc
j'estime en voie à la base pourquoi le
réseau social était et a été menée en
fait je me demande à quoi sert de la
chaîne youtube donne à tous par exemple
à l'époque en 2011 et un mec à 9h21 du
matin le 30 novembre 2 millions au ski à
archiver la chaîne youtube donne à tous
incroyable
les chroniques d'une fille dédicaces
déjà sa chute aux chirurgies esthétiques
type était déjà dans la bêtise le pubis
ma copine vient de se faire larguer à
c'est génial et norman fait des vidéos à
la même période je crois que c'était
déjà surpuissant mec mec bien le vieux
like le viola et qu'ils vieillissent
like a lancé m je veux mettre des
commentaires sur la chaîne devrait y en
avait huit c'était un bon agent pire
elles ont un mépris c'était quoi ça déjà
jean pierre est relancée palma qui
disait tu tries to me dire vous
critiquer à huy génial arrêté demetri
quitter je m'en souviens très bien on a
pas fait monsieur dream on n'a pas fait
monsieur dream alors cyprien ospreys et
anarchique de 2009 mais c'est lui même
qui l'a fait ces objets on est sur du
fric à danser vraiment chaînes supprimés
prouver les musées sovab au début ils
sont stupides tes vidéos y avait déjà
des doigts à l'époque c'est clairement
très sympa ton vidéos blogs
il avait en favori we will rock you mais
surtout plouffe des wingles mec qui
connaît ça c'est mon frère florent
charles webster qui m'a fait découvrir
savais que c'était dans la lignée de
trio et des gens qui fument de la plante
ab son père louis juin 2011 c'est là en
fait ça a commencé vraiment explosé
youtube j'ai l'impression cyprien
faisait des deux cent mille trois cent
mille voeux j'avais l'impression d'un
2011 ils avaient déjà beaucoup plus
cyprien norman nato et c'était en fait
pas du tout c'est vraiment à partir de
là que ça a complètement décoller c'est
marrant [ __ ] oui tu mettais des badges
à l'époque celui qui avait plus
d'abonnés de tous les temps qu'aux
médias en france
il te mettais des espèces de médailles
comme ça je me suis j'en avais aussi il
avait 4 millions 700 mille vies au total
la 19 mille abonnés mais en fait à
l'époque il ya vraiment eu un moment où
youtube ils ont mis en place ce truc
d'abonnement à la base c'était pas comme
ça à la base là benoît y avait le gros
bouton subscribe mais déjà il faisait
peur
jack quand tu cliques et ne sais pas ce
qui pouvait arriver à ta famille et
ensuite tu t'en foutais un peu tu te
laisser guider par la plateforme et
suggestions ce qui mettait en avant
comme vidéo de souza que c'était
essentiellement des vidéos de chats qui
marche et n'y avait pas cette
fidélisation qui actuellement d'ailleurs
je pense c'est peu de temps après je
pense ça devait être en 2012 juste avant
la fin du monde ce qu'elles ont mis le
design d'après voilà celui là
appartiennent à ils vont commencer à
influencer les gens à s'abonner donc là
on est un an après février 2012
et là tu es presque les 90 millions de
vues et à 3 en 2000 abonnés donc on voit
qu'il ya vraiment un gap entre les 20000
les trois entrants pin le design les
vues aussi youtube a vraiment explosé en
2011 2012
et moi j'étais là en mars 2011 mais j'ai
explosé mon compte en banque pour
acheter de quoi faire des vidéos mais
clairement pas le boss si je mets juste
youtube tout court cela juste sur des
chaînes youtube mais je pense que
youtube tout coup on aura des archives
bien bien vieille la avril 2005 avec
c'était à mon affreux c'était à moi
ignoble c'est génial et il y avait déjà
le délire de pseudo pour s'identifier à
l'horizon il fallait dire si c'était un
homme ou une femme qui cherchait un
homme ou une femme entre tel et tel un
taux d'incidence est favori message
vidéo mon profil atteint mais oui à sa
création youtube devait être un site de
rencontres l'idée était simple
ingénieuse les personnes qui ont cherché
l'amour pouvait poster une vidéo pour se
présenter et dire c'est qu'il
recherchait [ __ ] c'est génial
l'histoire de youtube est donc là on en
avril 2005 si je vais en avril 2006
logiquement l'interface aurait dû déjà
énormément changé à ce moment là oh là
là ok moi j'ai des trucs qui charge par
[ __ ] sur ce design a gelé pas connu tu
vois en 2008 voilà ok bah c'est comme ça
moi que je les connais youtube c'est
avec ce design là en 2008 j'avais 12 ans
et je devais vraiment tapé dofus dans
cette barre juste ici là y avait déjà
une vraie mise en avant de certaines
vidéos
ah oui et une haute et en mettant des
étoiles sur la [ __ ] c'est moi c'est
celui
est ce une tube là que j'ai connu en
premier c'est celui là voilà ça pour
dire que j'ai envie de voir du coup à
quoi ressemblait le site d'opus 22
septembre 2007
oui
fou j'avais 11 ans j'étais le plus gros
kick ou de la planète terre j'avais drop
et une maîtrise d'armes dans dofus la
maîtrise des dagues je crois je ne
pouvais plus j'étais un vrai coup qu'est
ce qu'on peut se battre et d'autres à
buzz google
le conte 2001 là on est sûr de
l'ancienneté colossal 2001 mais que
j'avais 5 ans faut pas abuser beaux mecs
ça a pas de temps vié mais à l'époque
ils adorent y mettre plein de boutons
comme ça alors coach des choses inutiles
cliquer sur ça on sait pas à quoi ça
sert et là tu as aussi des boutons est
ici adoré faire ça maintenant regarder
vers l inverse s'ajuste google une barre
et de boutons peu avec sa patte en vie
google n'a youtube je trouve qu'ils ont
eu vraiment plusieurs phases de on
voyait qu'il cherchait en vain cherché
quelle direction ils voulaient que la
plateforme prennent alors que google
google en fait c'est à l'époque c'est
l'idée était déjà génial or ils n'ont
pas modifié 30 ans de trucs par contre
maintenant il ya beaucoup d'outils à
google docs du google cheats google
google gmail google drive google maps
ils ont sorti plein d'outils mes trucs
de base est resté quasiment le même
c'est rigolo est ce que ces news que
j'ai ouïe est ce qu'il y avait un mec
absolue flash absolue flash a ressemblé
à quoi votre paroisse c'est ça que
j'imaginais quand je vous parlais
d'absolu flash c'est incroyable c'est le
vrai [ __ ] d'absolu flash c'était comme
les sites web de jeux flash sont morts
maintenant l'équivalent des jeux flash
c'est les jeux mobiles en fait c'est
terrible c'est fou je suis étonné
pourriez aujourd'hui aujourd'hui je suis
étonné pour rien ça gros je vai dans la
rue là je vais voir mes cachets de
baguettes je vais faire voir aux
incroyables et bien les amis je crois
qu'on a visités à ces deux sites web
datant des années 2000 on a eu assez de
nostalgie pour aujourd'hui n'hésitez pas
à même de ciel vous a plu et [ __ ] mais
c'est chaud ça génial de pouvoir voir
comment un outil que tu utilises
absolument tous les jours à l'heure
actuelle comment est-ce que c'était à
l'époque tu vas au début en plus parce
que c'est ça fait pas si longtemps qu'il
ya internet à nos parents ils ont grandi
zep internet j'ai hâte d'être dans 10
ans et de regarder cette vidéo et de
rire en me disant ah ah comme ct nas
avoir absolue faire je me fais plaisir
le petit dofus aussi [ __ ] mec cet
écran là qui m'a fait perdre quatre ans
de vie sociale dense où viendraient à
laisser la femme la nostalgie personnes
ont regardé je veux des artistes une
prochaine vidéo pour se taper j'arrête
ce mimiques dégueulasse
[Musique]